E aí
[Música]
E
desde que chegamos ao mundo caminhamos
rumo O que foi apresentado culturalmente
para nós mas esse não é o único caminho
existe muito mais coisas para viver e
experimentar e São tantos os caminhos
que muitas vezes acreditamos ser
impossível para nós
é com frequência pergunta as pessoas
sobre o ciclo da vida e na grande
maioria a resposta é nascer crescer
reproduzir
envelhecer e morrer mas também não é só
isso dentro de cada etapa Deve existir a
iva opção que o próprio ciclo representa
e essa evolução acontece por meio da
Coragem
e a coragem de encarar o desconhecido
superar os medos vencer barreiras e
quebrar paradigmas e as crenças que
limitam
e eu classifico evolução em três níveis
aonde no primeiro somos os espertos bom
de conversa peritos em dar desculpas
sabemos tudo
e muitas pessoas morrem tristes com uma
boa idade porque não evoluíram dessa
fase
é o segundo livro da evolução é a
inteligência é quando passamos a pensar
antes de fazer é o momento no qual
nós passamos a tomar decisões com base
de dados Fatos e estatísticas
ciência e matemática
e eu classifico também como a fase da
maturidade
O que é onde Assumimos a
responsabilidade
sobre as nossas atitudes ações e também
decisões
Ah e por fim vem a terceira fase da
evolução que é sabedoria
e é quando nos tornamos uma grande
referência nas mais importantes áreas da
vida
o mesmo que seja para família
E aí quando nossos exemplos
e passa um inspirar outras pessoas que
consequentemente contribui para a
construção do grande legado
e talvez neste momento você deve estar
se perguntando Mas como alcançar esses
três livres Hum será que é para mim qual
é o caminho Joel
É sim é para você e você já está no
caminho
e parabéns por estar aqui me escutando
e muitas pessoas estão em casa agora
fazendo as mesmas coisas de sempre e
acreditando
o que aquele é o único mundo que existe
a nossa casa não é o nosso mundo
o nosso bairro não é o nosso mundo
e a nossa escola não é o nosso mundo as
pessoas que a gente convive também não
sei o nosso mundo e nem o trabalho que
fazemos
Olá tudo isso é parte
porque existe muito mais coisas para ver
e conhecer a construir para experimentar
dentro e fora do planeta como vimos
agora recentemente o exemplo de foguetes
espaciais que até então era impossível e
agora o Foguete tem até
E é difícil acreditar
o que existe pessoas que não conhecem a
praia
a nossa cidade também
E é difícil acreditar que existe pessoas
que nunca andaram de avião
que não gostam de sushi e outra centena
de milhares que não consegue ver o mundo
como ele é
é tão cheio de ir
possibilidades e oportunidades de vida
melhor
e faz sentido para vocês aí
e
o meu conhecimento e as conexões que eu
adquiri ao longo da minha jornada
o seu para mim o maior poder que eu
tenho
e foram construídos com base de práticas
repetições
o trabalho duro e voluntariado
Oi e o complemento com as seguintes
frases
é a repetição
quem é a mãe de todas
as habilidades e ser voluntário é a
maneira mais inteligente de aprender e
de se conectar seja voluntário esse é o
caminho eu posso afirmar
o conhecimento é poder
a experiência e experimentação. Muitas
vezes não gostamos Porque Não
experimentamos
Eu por exemplo não gostava de estudar e
não gosto de estudar por isso estudei
muito pouco na escola mas vamos aprender
e são coisas diferentes
eu sou amante da experiência prática
Eu também não gostava de sushi
já estava acostumado com a mesma casa
porque não havia morava em outra melhor
eu passei um bom tempo acostumado com a
pobreza porque não sabia verdadeiro
gosto
e na abundância da prosperidade
a conexão é atitude
a proatividade
e já são
e com base nisso eu compartilho com
vocês em conhecimento que virou
propósito por onde eu empreendo um
conceito
e o conceito está relacionado com aquilo
que é para muitas pessoas Principalmente
as mais bem-sucedidas do mundo no
sentido financeiro
é algo simples ser entendido e aplicado
e quando a gente entende esse conceito e
aplica compreenderemos
o verdadeiro significado do ciclo ciclo
infinito
o ativo e passivo
tô me sentindo contágio o ativo e
passivo tem um aplicação diferente mas
não é sobre isso
e para quem não sabe passiva tudo aquilo
que te deixa a refém tudo aquilo que te
prende
o ativo é tudo que te liberta é o oposto
Quanto mais tempo mais dinheiro mais
recurso você investe mais Liberdade você
tem
eu quero ver alguns exemplos
o ativo e passivo no sentido de morar se
eu comprar um imóvel como forma de
investimento para alugar o revender é
ativo E se eu comprar para morar tem um
passivo se eu financiar o passivo fica
ainda maior porque porque você está
alienado ilimitado de possibilidades
devemos fazer perguntas para si mesmo
antes de tomar decisões como por exemplo
eu gosto do local aonde estão
construindo o prédio eu sei quem serão
os meus desenhos
não existe escola próximo para o meus
futuros filhos
e É próximo do trabalho da minha família
de modo geral
e a empresa que eu trabalho vai manter
empregado por 10 20 30 anos ou até
acabar de pagar esse financiamento
sabemos que não é uma realidade isso
pode ser um problema ainda maior
e ali de fazer perguntas temos que fazer
contas trazer a matemática para situação
do sentido de entender quanto esse
investimento renderia em uma aplicação
e acreditem muitas vezes essa renda dá
para pagar aluguel numa área nobre da
cidade
bom demais poder conhecer diversas
moradas antes de decidir de comprar ou
construir uma
e desconexões conviver com pessoas uma
classe acima da sua
ó consegue entender esse conceito se
aplica principalmente para os jovens que
estão em fase inicial da sua carreira
porque ingressar na faculdade ou no
mercado de trabalho com menos
preocupações
sobre os passivos
e certamente ar diminuir a chance de
fracasso aumentaram as chances de êxito
e na jornada na carreira
o ativo e passivo na forma de se
alimentar Depende se alimentar mal fora
de hora com comidas que prejudica o meu
metabolismo o meu corpo
O que é passivo ao contrário é ativo
sabemos o quanto alimentação ativa
saudável
influencia no nosso bem-estar na nossa
qualidade de vida
o ativo e passivo na forma de se
relacionar you
Ah depende
o seu convívio com pessoas que
subestimam meu potencial duvidando da
minha capacidade são reativas as minhas
ideias ações atitudes
O que é passivo só que aqui tem um ponto
que precisamos avaliar com carinho com
atenção porque muitas vezes essas
pessoas são membros da família muito
próximos
o que devemos respeitar porque às vezes
é por segurança nunca querem que eu mal
existe risco e às vezes elas não querem
que você corra o risco
me respeite mas não se limite a conhecer
mais pessoas
o ativo e passivo na forma de se
locomover e aqui eu trago dados
relevantes e assustadores sobre essa
questão
é que para mim é o maior problema do
país e vocês vão entender porquê
E qual é o meio de transporte que vocês
mais utilizam no dia a dia
E aí
e a quantos quilômetros Vocês moram da
empresa ou quantos quilômetros percorre
por dia
e sessenta por cento da frota Geral de
automóveis no Brasil percorre menos de 8
km por dia
434 para voltar sessenta por cento da
frota uma distância facilmente bicycle
tável
É mas não para por aí
o quanto custa esse modal
e sabemos que não existe automóvel que
pois também admiro reais por mês Qual é
a renda da maior parte da população
brasileira
1500/2000 reais se for r$ 2000 significa
que ele trabalha todos os dias levanta
de manhã e 6 horas e vai até a empresa
para trabalhar até o meio-dia para
alimentar o meio de transporte que ele
utiliza
bom e que por sua vez fica 95% do dia
parado em espaços que custam quase o
valor do mesmo Quanto custa a vaga de
uma garagem
É mas não para por aí talvez nesse
momento tenha muitas pessoas pensando
assim esse cara quer acabar com o
mercado de automóveis
é muito pelo contrário eu tô falando
é de uma situação que precisamos
compreender
e vocês vão entender agora sobre o
próximo. O porque muitas vezes o teu
cliente o a tua boca do Funil é tão
Ampla Por que que a estatística de
conversarmos sobre uma venda é muito
baixa
e é simples de entender por que que a
pessoa entra lá
demonstre interesse pelo seu produto ou
serviço e chega na hora do carrinho ela
não fecha
e Por que devemos incentivar a saúde
financeira a educação financeira a
mudança de hábito
Ah e por que isso faz parte da nossa
vida como um todo independente do Tem
condições ou não muitas pessoas precisam
e têm condições outras é necessidade mas
a maioria não o Brasil chegou a 63
milhões de pessoas no ano passado 2020
enquadrados no serviço de proteção ao
crédito
67 por cento das famílias estão
inadimplentes
e a gente mora no país de 210 milhões de
pessoas se a gente tirar as crianças até
18 anos que não pode comprar atrasou
e fala uma fatia gigantesca fora
E se a gente tirar a melhor idade que é
o nossos pais e avós já pagaram Prince
para entender
e o resultado daqui é cinco adultos a
cada dez a nosso redor a nível Brasil
estão na situação de inadimplência
e o comércio reclama mas não bota uma
vaga estacionamento para bicicleta
centivar o uso da bicicleta
O que é inteligência quem ganha saúde
mobilidade aquecimento global bolso
alegria felicidade
que são infinitas as possibilidades
consegue entender
e o que acontece com a sociedade
inadimplente gente
o aumento problema de Segurança Pública
roubo assalto quem tem dinheiro paga o
preço também não pode ser na rua para o
medo
e o que acontece com uma empresa
inadimplente Ela paralisa não cresce
é porque não tem recurso
o que acontece com a família
inadimplente e aqui eu volto lá no ponto
inicial da minha fala
é uma pessoa não conhece a praia porque
o pai não tem condições de levar ela
praia
é tão pelo mesmo motivo não experimentou
uma gastronomia diferente uma viagem por
causa da inadimplência falta de recurso
bom e como consequência briga separação
filho crescendo sem pai
É isso aí educação
é o problema de saúde emocional
a saúde mental cresce exponencialmente
no Brasil e no mundo
e profissionais de regas e
Oi e da Saúde
e trazem soluções para remediar
a diminuir a taxa de turnover bournout
É mas não entende que causa
é porque o indivíduo que está na de
implant ele não produz lá na empresa
porque ele tá subir pressão psicológica
família credores advogados juízes
todos lutando para receber parte daquela
dívida como é que cara vai trabalhar em
empresas que não contrata quem tá no
Serasa no serviço de proteção ao crédito
tem empresa que não contrata que tem
automóvel porque tá entendendo isso se
consegue entender como a gente muda o
mundo
de forma simples
o ativo e passivo na forma do tempo
com o tempo a nosso maior ativo Ele é
igual a gelo
e mete todo dia em algumas pessoas vivem
no tempo do passado e o pior
criando mais problemas e se acostumando
com aquilo
outras vive no tempo do amanhã que
certamente não sabemos se existirá de
fato
precisamos estar aqui e agora fazer o
máximo que podemos com aquilo que temos
aproveitar todos os recursos e
transformá-los em ativas
e essa minha causa
e
[Música]
quando não existe mais formas a gente se
reinventa as vezes colocar a pessoa numa
situação de necessidade
e ajudar ela dizer um não' para ela e
ajudar ela a segunda forma de mudar a
cultura é isso aqui educação dados Fatos
e estatísticas matemática
comunicação assertiva direta objetiva
é isso muda uma cultura é
E aí
[Música]
e essa é a minha causa e
se tornar a vida das pessoas
mais ativas
[Música]
significar a vida nas cidades e
e
[Música]
contribuir para um mundo mais
sustentável mais saudável se a gente
realmente quer viver o mundo mais
abundante mais próximos mas próximo
precisamos o que incentivar novas formas
de viver de consumir demorar de se
locomover
e aqui pessoas ativas seu mais feliz é
o vídeo mais experiências possui muito
muito muito muito mais conexões
as pessoas ativas
Hakuna Matata não tem problemas não tem
problemas que não podem ser
administrados ou resolvidos de forma
simples
Olá sejam mais ativos Muito obrigado
[Música]
E aí